who would have thought being safety
conscious could be made trendy from
Topman to Urban Outfitters and boohoo
man among others many are selling items
that look like stab vests branded as
fashionable it's a trend that's been
propelled by popular culture grime
artist storm Z wore a stab proof vest
designed by Banksy at last year's
Glastonbury Festival he might have been
making a statement but they've also been
seen on catwalks
now there's the option to have them in
your wardrobe we found this one from an
online retailer for just 10 pounds at
first glance it does look like a real
one so if someone was to mistake it for
the real deal it wouldn't offer any
protection at all father of two Dean
door isn't surprised that's just fashion
so fashion this you know he's creating
what people want you know if there's a
need for it and people can obviously
fill the gaps when Dean stepson was
robbed at knifepoint twice he decided to
make slash proof clothing out of
necessity
he's worried these vests could attract
unwanted attention if you're walking
around in a stat proof vest and you're
gonna get other people who want to put
it to the test I want to challenge you
you know they may feel you've got
something to hide
but for the generation these items are
aimed at they see no issue there is an
element of glamourizing in this there's
no doubt about this what worries me more
is the fact that for many young people
this is just a normal garment that you
would wear they don't think about what
it's really saying you do not have to go
around wearing established you should
not have to go around wearing a star
vest Lydia and Joshua work with people
affected by knife crime and know people
who are victims of it but they say they
would buy one you see people in the
street that are wearing camouflage
trousers and tops and jumpers and track
suits and they saw that they want to go
out and fry it and I guess bomb another
country it's just a fashion statement so
I feel like if you're going to use
something like that and say that it's
almost to ignite violence I don't think
that makes sense I've seen a music
videos
I see people wear on the street it's not
it's not like that's just nothing it's
just ordinary James ham save
on yourself now I'm gone I plan that
planning gay or not not all of the vests
are fake this brand told us they do
offer some protection they and retailers
boohoo mance said they would never use
fashion to condone violence we
approached top man and urban outfitters
for comment and following that the
retailer removed this product from their
website the Home Office told us they are
determined to do all they can to tackle
knife crime these vests may just be
fashioned and a form of expression but
for critics there's no hiding from the
apparent glamorization of an item that
could save lives
Asha hari nag Sky News